jimmy has made a documentary on the 86
minutes once upon a time in queens why
did you make a documentary on uh the
mets what's uh what was the cell many
people have
wanted to make this documentary but this
is the first time that the mets and
baseball have cooperated because there
are some unflattering depictions of
not just the team but the game and
there's pretty crazy stuff going on i
mean these guys were almost all on
amphetamines
they were
almost all doing cocaine uh after the
game before the game you know they were
there were arrests mid-season there were
multiple fights there were fights with
other teams there were fights between
players it's
you know crimes were committed a team
plane was destroyed
like crazy stuff so why did the mets
agree to this documentary if it's so
unflattering it's isn't that kind of
mind-blowing because they're smart
because i think they felt hey listen
everybody knows the story now books have
been written
stories have been told and this is the
truth this is what happened and it was a
great team and it is part of what's fun
about baseball good or bad gary is great
in the documentary you know gary
remembers
gary delabot
about that series that yeah bob
that i think probably most of the
players don't even remember let's
compliment baba fuhai i'm very very
amazed by his memory yeah like gary
remembered that the ball hit the news
day sign dave henderson hit a home run
in the top of the 10th to make it five
to three and that's when you thought it
was over and i was sitting with my dad
down the left field line it made this
like loud metal clang it was the
greatest night i've ever had with my dad
you know it's interesting that gary you
had that for you was one of the best
nights of your life with your dad
because many of the players we learned
talking to them had
very bad or very complicated
relationships with their fathers and
keith hernandez's dad keith says the
biggest mistake he ever made was getting
his dad a satellite dish because his dad
would call him after every at-bat this
is an adult man who's already been mvp
of the national league getting yelled at
by his father in the locker room after
after at bats daryl strawberry's dad
would tell him he was worthless and he
was garbage and when daryl was getting
booed and you know everybody was you
know mocking him and he had his his drug
problems he said it didn't bother him
because when your father calls you
worthless your whole life
a group of strangers
shouting it at you
doesn't make an impact the best the guy
who seemed to have had the best
relationship with his dad was dwight
gooden and dwight gooden's mom shot his
dad but jimmy howard who's the star of
this show lenny dykstra is lenny robin's
um fiancee
yeah
is the star of the documentary why is he
the kid on the team he was like the
young guy who came in and he was small
and people were like what are you the
bat boy you know one of those deals and
um
he gave himself the nickname nails that
was a self
i didn't know that i always thought the
team loved him so much they called him
nails i had no idea he came up with that
himself that's just unbelievable i don't
know if the team loved him because he
talks about like one night um he was
just out of his mind it was the night
before a game he's in the lobby of the
hotel
kicking gary carter's door just he's a
donkey kicking the door over and over
again gary come on gary just drunk and
crazy and gary wouldn't come out gary
wouldn't come out finally the door flies
open and gary grabs him by the neck and
pin it lifts him up above his head and
pins him against the wall he's like
don't you ever [ __ ] come into my room
again don't you ever [ __ ] do this
again and he never did it again you know
these guys they don't give a [ __ ] about
anything they're like they're overgrown
they're men but they're kids they're
like they're playing a kid's game and
they behave this way but it's i guess
maybe that leads to their greatness the
fact that they don't give a [ __ ] they
don't worry about anything you know one
of the most i think haunting stories of
in the documentary is um
is about um good and they're talking
about when lenny bias died you remember
len bias he was uh
the university of maryland yeah and he
was picked number one by the boston
celtics and two days later he overdosed
on cocaine and it was a real tragic like
kind of it was a moment for them they
were like oh my god that you know this
could happen to us
about four hours after he has this like
moment where he's like oh my god this
could happen to us he calls his drug
dealer and says uh get me the lenny bias
stuff oh my god i didn't know all that
actually i will watch this thing